accepter qu'une situation qui nous
rendent malheureux dur depuis un an deux
ans cinq ans dix ans acceptez ça et
avoir conscience qu'on l'accepte c'est
quelque chose que la conscience humaine
n'est pas prête à supporter c'est
quelque chose de beaucoup trop lourd de
beaucoup trop pesant et on préfère à
toujours se dire que si on en est là
c'est parce qu'on n'a pas eu de chance
c'est parce qu'on a fait des mauvaises
rencontres c'est parce qu'il nous est
arrivé des choses qui ne dépendait pas
de nous et on aura bien évidemment
raison de le dire il y aura forcément
des choses qui auront joué en notre
défaveur sans qu'il nous soit possible
de faire autrement bien sûr pour Sartre
il existe une part d'inéluctable mais
selon lui ça ne doit pas nous rendre
aveugle à notre propre pouvoir à notre
propre influence à notre propre maîtrise
de notre vie de ce que nous voulons être
du sens que nous donnons à notre
existence